in previous videos we've talked about
some of the major schools of thought
that emerged at the end of the joe
dynasty especially as we start to enter
the warring states period the famous
hundred schools of thought and most
prominent amongst them is confucianism
started or based on the teachings of
confucius who lived around 2500
years ago
and it was all about how does a society
live in harmony confucianism is based on
a lot of teachings that were already
part of chinese culture and confucius
one could say put them together but put
them together in a contextual way and
made them more relevant and you can see
on this diagram confucianism was really
focused on the ethical but confucius
himself tried to apply some of his
teachings into the more practical realm
now out of that hundred schools of
thought you also have taoism that we
talk about in other videos now taoism
is really based on this idea of the tao
or
the way and we could do many videos on
taoism
but it's this idea of letting go and you
could even think of it as going with the
flow and the simplicity a return to
nature
freeing yourself from desires and it was
definitely more philosophical and more
focused on the spiritual than
confucianism now in other videos we talk
about legalism which was a key part of
the qin dynasty which was the first real
imperial dynasty china is named after
the qin dynasty but was fairly harsh it
was really this idea that hey human
beings really need strong leadership
sometimes harsh leadership in order for
society to actually work now the school
of thought that we have here up at top
buddhism is interesting because it did
not emerge from that hundred schools of
thought period that we get at the end of
the joe dynasty buddhism emerges in
india at around the same time roughly 2
500 years ago with the teachings of
buddha a hindu prince who lived in
northeast india southern nepal and his
teachings are in some ways you could
almost view as a reformation of hinduism
at the time a return to the idea that
someone through meditation through
realization can become one with at least
in buddhism the emptiness nirvana can
escape from clinging to desires of this
non-reality that we think we live in now
we've talked about in previous videos
how the qin dynasty was really based on
this legalist philosophy but the han
dynasty is considered the golden age of
china now under the han dynasty
confucianism really took hold and became
the dominant philosophical structure of
china and to some degree would stay that
way
now at the end of the han dynasty china
goes into a chaotic period for several
hundred years until we get to the sixth
century when the sui dynasty is able to
finally reunify china for the most part
and in that interim confucianism starts
to
give way to some degree to
both taoism and buddhism these things
that are more focused on the spiritual
areas where confucianism was not as
interested and what's interesting about
buddhism even though it started in india
famously ashoka and the third century
bce really becomes a patron of buddhism
and even sends missionaries out to
spread it
and it comes to china via central asia
and southeast asia it really takes on a
uniquely chinese
nature as it enters china really it
eventually evolves into mahayana
buddhism and under the tang dynasty
which is considered one of the high
points of chinese civilization buddhism
is really able to take hold especially
in the early tang dynasty however as we
get into the late tang dynasty buddhism
starts to get some pushback and even
gets persecuted to some degree people
arguing that hey buddhism is it's a
foreign belief system in some ways it's
not concerned enough with social
cohesion it's all about the individual
through meditation trying to separate
themselves from reality becoming one
with the emptiness and so at around the
same time some would argue in reaction
to the strength of buddhism you have a
movement known as neo-confucianism
taking the central ideas of confucius
but using some frameworks and
terminology from taoism and buddhism and
there were many neo-confucian
philosophers that began to emerge in the
late tang dynasty but it's really
considered the sung dynasty where
neo-confucianism
really takes hold and the most famous of
the neo-confucian philosophers sometimes
ranked second to confucius himself in
terms of influence on chinese philosophy
is ju
he lived from 11 30 to 1200
and he's most known for his one could
say curation of confucian texts he
famously curated the four books analects
of confucius mencius or dementius by
mencius great learning doctrine of the
mean written by confucian followers this
curation of confucian thought shortly
after jude sees life it becomes the
bedrock of the chinese education system
and the civil service examinations as we
go through the wan ming and qing
dynasties all the way to the early 20th
century
now he also wrote books on tradition and
rituals which are in some ways very
confucian because they're focused on the
practical they're focused on the family
they're focused on social cohesion but
he also dabbled in the more spiritual
wrote extensively about notions of tai
chi which is really a taoist or even a
pre-taoist idea thinking about what is
the fundamental nature of the universe
and the tai chi itself is the great
ultimate sometimes represented by the
yin yang symbol really this is showing
tai chi divided into this dualistic
nature between
yin and yang how at the center of each
or the extreme of each they become the
other he writes about chi this life
force or energy
and once again these are ideas he takes
from taoism
but in neo-confucian thought there's
this idea of you shouldn't just detach
yourself from physical reality you
should study it there's an order there's
a logic to the universe that could be
understood and because of the influence
of the neoconfusions especially their
focus on belief in the order and logic
of the universe it's no coincidence that
the sung dynasty saw some of the major
technological advancements not just of
china but of the world
advancements that really put china at
the technological forefront remember
europe at this time is in the middle
ages the middle east is under the golden
age of islam but it's really the chinese
who are pushing the envelope here now
just get a flavor of some of ju c's
writing
original mind is principle as derived
from tai chi in itself unmoved and
perfectly good while physical nature on
the other hand is principle mixed with
material force qi
it is the aroused state involving both
good and evil the two natures however
are always interfused one the substance
and the other function so once again
even though he was confucian he was a
confucian philosopher this is very
taoist in nature and even this notion of
talking about original mind is principle
in itself unmoved and perfectly good
this
feels very buddhist or even hindu in its
thinking now one could debate whether it
was to what degree it was influenced by
buddhism it is a very central idea that
all of reality all of sentience is
emergent from this atman from this
brahman from this original mind emerges
from the emptiness
but what makes it neoconfusion is beyond
the metaphysical beyond the
philosophical they bring it down to
reality they bring it down to practical
concerns how does this affect how one
governs how does this affect how one
should learn how does this affect
how one should be in social harmony with
those around them